foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
la la la la la
la
la
la la la
[Music]
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
okay now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
mangoes
[Music]
bring my mangoes
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango
[Applause]
don't want me to me
[Music]
[Music]
Gloria looking for a place to watch some
news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know of a guy who fits
that bill a progressive with political
will but David packed him shows you your
political knowledge science
who's the current president of the
United States
who's the current
I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
sign up foreign
what
did China
[Music]
I've been growing this one huge Heather
all summer it's time to pluck it
self
[Music]
I'm worried about my espresso machine
I'm not that can be your headline
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my Lane
you're like
um
just exploded I'm sorry about getting
rid of the machine felt him down and
turn them into prison bars pillows I'm
not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers the
lawyers are lawyers
[Music]
just pillows who did this attack who did
this Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said
[Music]
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that it should know if you're not giving
my phone I said arrest me I've done
nothing Mommy so no we're not gonna
arrest you I swear
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you some Phyllis I'm worried about
my legs
Okay Melt them down and turn them into
prison bars
pillow all right thanks Mike Take Care
thank you bye all right welcome
everybody one of the most anticipated
debates of the 2022 election season it
is fetterman V Oz with a number of
additional story lines not all of them
particularly thrilling I must say but I
will tell you all of the different story
lines have entered this debate which
will start just 30 minutes from now we
will have wall-to-wall floor-to-ceiling
yard to garage coverage of the this
debate and I can't tell you how glad I
am that you were here with me no I
really I mean listen you could be
watching Stephen Crowder right now okay
and while that might be a much better
experience for you
I'm glad that you're here instead of
with Stephen Crowder is that fair to say
do we make ourselves understood on that
basis thank you
um now
let's talk about this debate
this is the Pennsylvania senate race
we have a situation
in which a number of different Senate
races could determine whether
Republicans Or democrats control the
Senate starting in January
this race is one of the races if not the
race most likely to determine that if it
were to come down to one race
in a world that made sense
quack Dr Mehmet Oz would be losing by
50.
okay
the world doesn't make sense and we have
a one-point race at this point in time
and as you can see there was a time you
know times were good in Late July times
were still pretty good in late August
where it was a seven point uh lead for
John fetterman and then suddenly they
said sir it's a four-point lead
and then suddenly it was a three-point
lead and then suddenly it is a 1.3 point
lead this is essentially a toss-up
Pac-Man's a loser this isn't about me
this is about fetterman and this is
about Oz
is a quack TV doctor in way over his
head not even really from Pennsylvania
John fetterman is the lieutenant
governor
with extensive policy knowledge in a
number of different areas
in a sane country Oz would be laughed
out of this thing
but this isn't the same country sadly
and so this is where we are
and we are going to have this debate
starting very very soon we are
monitoring CNN as well because they may
be carrying it but you know what I want
to do
let's
um
let's get this set up
I I hate it when we have these issues
let's just get this set up right now and
properly framed for everybody I respect
everybody too much to leave this to the
last minute so let me get that set up
and we'll just dump it here and we'll
enlarge
and let's also set this to the highest
possible resolution
and get the volume up okay good and then
as needed we'll go to other streams okay
so this starts very very very very very
very very very
soon and I can't tell you how glad I am
uh to have you here there are a few
things I want to go over with you just
because I have the opportunity while we
are all here uh first and foremost thank
you and welcome to Jason sigmaier who
just gifted a subscription at
joinpakman.com yesterday I mentioned we
have free subscriptions to give away to
my website we've got them we need a
system okay to give them away and the
system is very very straightforward it
is first come first served if you want a
free membership go to davidpackman.com
free membership I don't know if this was
a joke but someone emailed me after last
night's stream and said David can you
tell me how to get a free membership
not by emailing me okay that goes in the
toilet
davidpackman.com free membership you
just put your name and email in we will
go in order okay that's it it's super
super simple
super chats coming in early voting
continues to break records especially in
Georgia yes I am going to have a report
tomorrow about those records so I don't
want to
I don't want to self-cock as the term
may be now on that issue
sir thanks for all the debate coverage
and all you do love the world famous
bonus show yes where is my bonus show
hold on
damn that's not it I can't believe it's
legal David I just can't believe it no
that's not it either okay anyway I don't
have that but yes the bonus show very
very important over on Twitch I want to
say thanks to that crazy guy sedated
Trish the dish and erroneous for their
twitch Prime subscriptions let's
continue with more things that we must
discuss
um I have uh okay wait what I'm trying
to think the right order to do these
things and
uh not gonna do voicemails now
okay I've I've limited time so let's
just get into some of these other things
my colleague John sent me a few items we
might want to take a look at this is
blatant racism at a parent's meeting I
don't know anything about this let's
take a look
to say good night and he was I can't
hear a word of that hold on let's let's
take it back to the beginning
I remember when I went to his bedroom
okay let's see if we can just crank it
to say good night and he was crying
because of the abuse that he was
enduring in this school system and why
don't you stay in Mexico
oh my God
oh my God
Dear God
listen guys I mean all these Irish
Americans complaining about stuff that
they don't like why didn't your
grandparents stay in Ireland I mean if
you never like anything you should have
to go back to wherever the last place
your family lived you should you have no
right to complain how idiotic is that
huh
that's indicative of what our kids are
expecting yeah
and that's no he's sharing a story right
now that's indicative of what our kids
are experiencing
please
telling me this is old I've never seen
this before so I'm listening and
learning here
because this is the greatest country in
the world
[Music]
no immigrants should be allowed to
complain
that's it wow unbelievable
um here's another clip here is profit
profit Kat Kerr
channeling God and declaring that Trump
is President right now I didn't know
that but apparently Trump is President
let's see
what is she holding guys
for they will say these very words
we don't want to say this
we tried to prove it wasn't true
that it was a lie
but Trump won the 2020 election the he
is the president of the United States of
America and I will give him his four
more years
so she's a medium now right is she
channeling God right now this is God
speaking
there will not need to be an election to
cause that to happen oh how convenient
for I have already spoken from the
courtroom of Heaven
even into the unknown space
into the spirit realm the Physical Realm
those words have already been spoken is
this church tax exempt
the Trump
who was My Chosen person is My Chosen
person to sit in the seat of the White
House
who will wipe up this mess
like a mop bucket so there's no trace of
it is that a hot dog that's a really
weird thing to be holding really really
strange stuff here's another one I hope
this isn't old you know I mean it's like
it was posted to Reddit three days ago
teacher berating a student who didn't
stand from The Pledge oh God
are gonna sit there on your butt
Chevrolet
foreign
the end is someone not standing to the
pledge for the pledge indicative of the
end
where are you from Mexico or oh no oh no
I was born here oh my God
stand up for the flag
let's hear God
uh I hope I hope that teacher was fired
man that is that is horrible horrible
stuff
um
jeez we we have some real issues in this
country I hate to uh I hate to have to
tell you fine folks I know none of you
would ever do stuff like this
I want to say thanks to fjorkum
geostigma
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at seven ladies and gentlemen
if you're just joining us one of the
most anticipated debates in the 2022
election cycle is just 20 minutes away
it is John fetterman versus Mehmet Oz
let's now discuss some of the context
that is taking place here I already told
you the importance of this race this is
a race that could ultimately determine
who controls the Senate who controls the
Senate
um one of the story lines as of late has
been John fetterman's Health some months
ago John fetterman suffered a stroke we
know that as of a couple of weeks ago he
was having an auditory processing issue
wherein he struggled to
um
sort of accurately process the meaning
of audio questions and so in an
interview in a couple interviews he used
a text a speech to text closed
captioning sort of machine
um and he was criticized and people
started making the case that it's a
cognitive issue his doctors have said it
is not a cognitive issue but of course
there are questions about what kind of
shape he will arrive in tonight I am
going to warn uh everybody right now
it is absolutely fair game for us to
talk about and I will talk about
uh the sort of Optics of how fetterman
does tonight
but if we start seeing sort of like
um you know disability shaming and
making fun of and and this sort of thing
you're probably just getting banned okay
and so moderators uh just be aware we're
not going to do you know like this overt
ableism stuff but listen this is a
political question and to the extent
that fetterman
May struggle to communicate tonight if
he does when you have a race that's 1.3
points separating the two
it's something that very well may be a
factor uh for voters and that's not I'm
not going to pretend that that's not the
case
um Nicholas McMullen says David any
interest in Dixon versus Whitmer tonight
I feel governorships are consequential I
already covered a Dixon versus Whitmer
debate
and so tonight we're doing fetterman Oz
because this is I believe the only one
uh is that right is this the only one
hold on let me take a look
was there another one scheduled
um
yeah as far as I know it is so I'm not
accusing you of this Nicholas but no
matter which debate I cover someone will
pop saying pop up saying you should be
covering a different debate tonight this
is the debate I'm covering so if you
want to see a different debate there may
be other channels with other debates but
this is the one we're covering tonight
David I'm strapping in and preparing for
Mehmet Oz to teach a master class in
ableism I would be prepared for that
please vote my Pennsylvania Brethren the
race is too close agreed Eric very much
agreed and thanks to guitar goddess eriv
twiz and stay calm and carry on gifting
five Subs that's a total of seven
putting us at 14. really appreciate that
we have a goal of 100 new website
members and twitch subscribers tonight I
hope you help us get there
chair Fender says David sir did you see
Trump's favorite Indian cricket player
to mispronounce Virat Kohli his historic
performance in Australia please play I
have not why
[Music]
and I won't talk about the third element
of the bathroom oh I actually don't have
the other one here handy
okay in any case we are uh continuing
continuing continuing as we are moments
away from this debate and I so
appreciate
um everybody who is joining us people
are asking me am I actually showing the
debate yes this is a live stream right
now I am communicating with you audio
visually
through
uh the internet
and the subject matter of today's stream
is the Oz fetterman debate that debate
starts in 15 minutes and we will be
transmitting such debate
like such as here if you're hearing me
now you need to do nothing to get the
debate in 15 minutes okay period
I I don't know how else I can explain
this
thanks to Admiral bones for the twitch
Prime subscription other super chats
coming in Ian accepts me for the debate
I'm covering I appreciate that
David can you add a message to donated
membership so we don't have to give
Google 30 for our bad jokes
uh I that's not functionality that we
have at this particular time
but we can look at that thanks to Lenny
peppers for the twitch Prime
subscription as well okay let me take a
look at a couple other things here that
I have uh in my media stream
um
I guess there was kind of a tense moment
in the zeldon debate okay
okay this is I don't know why that's so
important you all I know is that we
could do more well when I say it could
be more excuse me I'm speaking we could
do so much more if there's a nationwide
band it's only a state ban on teenagers
be able to get guns
assault weapons I mean that's what
happened in Buffalo a teenager walked
into a shop and was able to buy an
assault weapon the kind you use on
Military battlefields it happened just
yesterday in St Louis all right well
liezel been allowing her to speak which
is very nice of him
[Music]
um
let's see what else I have that I would
want to look at with you now
um
Doug masteriano is now making fun of
Josh Shapiro's height I mean the guy is
like the central career politician he's
being groomed hold on hang on hang on
are you telling me that he's not going
to last two weeks he's not going to get
on stage with you and debate you is that
what you're saying uh he won't I even
offered to get him a box to stand on I
mean so I mean what can I say I don't
know how to help no no no but is is he
so is he that's super funny mastriano is
going to get crushed like it's it's not
even it's really not even going to be
close I hope he's prepared for it
um let's see what else I have if
anything of interest for us before the
debate starts
um
Trump was called Blake Masters was
called by Donald Trump that's uh not not
really finding that particularly
interesting
um Herschel Walker commenting on Donald
Trump's tweets
uh oh previous his previous tweets let's
take a listen to that
student fault
he gave up our energy
and now I didn't like so many tweets
Donald D but he had some good policies I
didn't like the truths that did I just
said Donald don't do that he did it
anyway
but let me tell you his policy was great
you know it would be really interesting
to actually ask Herschel Walker which
specific policies of trump did you
actually like
I it's unclear he'd be able to explain
it
uh let's see what else we have
Marcia Blackburn is jumping on the voter
fraud bandwagon early saying Google is
rigging it
files on Google
yes this is something that appears to be
intentional and purposeful so you have
to ask are they doing this as an in-kind
contribution to the Democratic campaigns
now our Republican conference has met
with Google and also one of our major
male vendors and the answers we got from
Google were not satisfactory and you
take a campaign like Marco Rubio's where
they intentionally suppress his emails
you know part of what's going on and
none of these folks seem to want to talk
about it
is that some of these Republicans
send out 10 or even 20 fundraising
emails a day and there is absolutely
something that starts to happen
algorithmically if you're as a campaign
emailing people 10 to 20 times a day
it is more likely that Google is going
to start using their spam machine
learning uh algorithms to believe that
that is spam
so part of it is by their own doing
um a lot of these people have no clue
what's going on as you as you may or may
not have noticed thanks to Robert Lynn
for signing up at joinpakman.com your
new member number 17 today also want to
say a big thank you to papa bear Lo-Fi
potato and Michael Devore for the twitch
Prime subscriptions putting us at 20. uh
super chats continue to come in
um David why do you think Trump hates
dogs or dogs as he calls them you'd
think he'd be into the unquestioning
Loyalty thing it's sort of the same
reason Trump doesn't seem that big on
kids
just he's like that
currently living in Pennsylvania says
Crimson Siegel I really hope my future
Senator isn't a TV doctor doesn't seem
too qualified to me I agree
Kai James says thanks for helping me
through long nights of poor mental
health with your amazing insights much
love from the UK P.S any chance you can
shout out a charity hike I did recently
tours for change absolutely I just did
from my recollection says Bay photo
fetterman wasn't all that great during
the Democratic primary debate nervous
about the race hoping for the best yeah
fetterman was not the best performer in
the democratic debate he's the best
candidate he was not the best debater
I'm also worried about that
I was going to leave a wisecrack remark
asking if this was a live stream or not
but my wireless keyboard ran out of
batteries before I could hit submit so
please disregard this message
that's fine Eric
thanks to Lucky roller Rich says sir
what does it say about America if we add
two more celebrity senators and a TV
governor in Arizona will Democrats have
to rethink candidates yeah I mean
Democrats may also have to jump on
playing these lowest common denominator
games it'll be sad
it'll be very very sad but uh it will
probably be a
it will probably be
a moment of Reckoning of sorts
a first time chatter on Twitch
liquidation says I'm Lee I live in
Pennsylvania leaning towards fetterman
but will like to see how the debate goes
I don't understand how anyone's
undecided at this point it's like you've
got a weaponized Maga type
uh clueless Republican and then you have
fetterman with experience and coherent
policies like either you're just a MAG
at at this point
or you're voting fetterman I just I
don't understand how someone could be
undecided I really don't
some people are saying this this user
just wants attention no I mean I'm I'm
taking it at face value and assuming
that it's that's the truth I don't know
uh
uh all right do we want to dump in a
quick voicemail before we get too far
into what we're doing
um let's see what I have as far as
voicemails go
hey David this is Evan in Colorado
um just having a thought here uh
probably watch too much YouTube but I I
get recommended this channel for like uh
can other people hear that it is so low
on on my mixer
let me try a different voicemail because
that was just the the level was so low
uh people saying let's try Whitney okay
so I was wondering 100 days I'm about
the devil Judaism oh when you try to
like give people a bunch of extra
reasons uh why God wouldn't love you why
isn't that the devil
and is that like a part of the demo
scheme to get you to realize how God
hates you
that is probably more than I can really
address today Whitney so let's
let's put a pause on that and sort of um
sort of move on because I think that
that that may just be a bit much
um
what's going on with subscriber numbers
they seem to be blowing up yeah oh so
listen to this I I have to tell you I
don't I genuinely have no idea what's
going on
we've somehow gained three like roughly
3 000 YouTube subscribers in the last 24
hours
I I don't have a clue what is going on
I I mean I I don't know one thing I did
mention yesterday and on the podcast
today
is that we found out this found out my
colleague John dug through our analytics
I didn't even know that this was a
metric that we could find
last month
4.3 million different people watched our
clips and as you can see we only have
1.5 million subscribers this means that
somewhere out there there are 2.8
million people who watched at least one
video and didn't subscribe I heard from
a bunch of these people who said David I
haven't subscribed because I already get
fed your videos all the time
I understand that
Please Subscribe because it is one of
the main factors after click-through
rate that tells YouTube should we
recommend this content it's like
cumulative it's like compounding
interest okay there are 2.8 million of
you out there I'm not saying people who
haven't watched the videos I'm just
talking to people who have there's 2.8
million of you out there from not last
month alone we saw the videos and didn't
subscribe now assume even half hated the
videos
that's still 1.4 million additional
people who watched the videos and didn't
subscribe just if we can get a quarter
of those folks
we basically are at 2 million
you're and and people are saying I don't
want all your videos in my subscription
feed
you can subscribe
and then turn off notified send to feed
if that's to just you can say don't send
the videos into my feed
you can do all these different things
okay anyway
Please Subscribe all right this is my
please uh my please clap moment and we
are moments away here okay yes you can
do this you can do this everybody all
right super chat's coming in street over
Bridge another pot calling Kettle the
Republicans have more celebrities
running for office but Hollywood lives
I don't think I understand that I'm not
sure I know what that individual is
saying
does anybody know I'm not sure
but I appreciate all super chats all
super chats
um
am I having a problem with our new
discount yes I am I can't believe it's
legal David I just can't believe it I I
it's it's bizarre it really is
um I'm going to mention that once and
only once okay
we are primarily funded by people who
sign up for memberships on our website
okay it's not an exaggeration we keep
98.1 percent of every one of those
payments nobody's taking slices I want
to invite you right now if you've liked
the debate streams we've got the white
paper on how to argue politics with
people effectively all these things that
we're doing okay go to joinpakman.com
hit the sign up button see this coupon
code big voting 22 forget about that use
the better coupon code Obama okay
this is extraordinary Obama huge
discount and I will thank every single
one of you Alex Jones hates it hates it
when people sign up for memberships that
man's a loser right absolutely hates it
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yes I will thank
every single person who today gets a
membership on my website and we will
hopefully get to a hundred have you
considered doing a super match on
donated memberships for a limited time
only how would that work a super match
on donated memberships
oh like I will match the donation that's
not a bad idea I would consider doing
that
that seems like a good idea yeah let's
let's figure out a way to make that
happen
um other voicemails okay yeah I'll do
like I'll do like one or two more
voicemails let's see
hey David sir um this is Rusty in
Oklahoma and I'm very much looking
forward to seeing you in that Star Wars
movie with producer Pat as the angry
weatherman right so on today's bonus
show one of the things we talked about
we talked about the story how actor Mark
Hamill sent 500 drones to Ukraine and
one of the things a lot of people don't
know is that Mark Hamill is a big fan of
the David packman show Mark Hamill sent
me a Mazel Tov uh for the birth of uh my
daughter Mark Hamill all-around good guy
big time Progressive fan of the show
okay
the topic came up of what if I had a
cameo on a forthcoming Star Wars movie
which of course isn't going to happen
but if it did
the idea I had was that the scene would
be as follows it's the Maas Eisley
Tavern the Cantina sorry the Mas Eisley
Cantina
and as the camera is panning around in
the Cantina there would be a TV now I
know that it does it's not clear there
is TV in the Star Wars universe but
imagine that there was
the camera pans by and on the TV it's
Star Wars Universe newscaster David
packman and I'll wear the you know
whatever right like I'll it'll be it
would all make sense and I'm like
reporting about something that happened
on Tatooine or something like that that
would be my dream Cameo on a Star Wars
movie but yeah
can't say it's gonna happen anytime soon
thanks to Matt Grant Jason sickmeyer
Miranda groover and Cameron Edwards for
signing up on my website really really
appreciate that also thanks to Amber
Fritz for gifting a membership if you
want a free membership folks they're
available
go to davidpackman.com free membership
that's all it takes also thanks to the
FED guy for signing up via twitch Prime
um see this is exactly what I'm talking
about the FED guy who just subscribed
with prime says the only reason I knit I
never subscribed on YouTube is you were
already at the top of my home screen I
have just subscribed though I very much
appreciate that I very much appreciate
that that matters you matter
and that is a great great thing Spencer
David is there any policy or position
you agree with the right wing on
it's not so black and white but there
are issues and I've talked about them
before there are some very narrow
economic issues in which the right has a
point that should be considered by the
left
I have Clips on this
David sir your Facebook stream is titled
incorrectly cheers from Australia I know
uh we there was a glitch with restream
and Facebook today
and we were not able to uh correctly
title The Stream and I apologize for
that thanks to Mike Lashbrook for
signing up on my website at
joinpakman.com
I will try to fix the title of the
Stream
on Facebook when the debate starts let's
see
um
okay the debate seems like it's going to
start any second I'm wondering if I
should have like a backup stream just in
case this one doesn't start but
I think it might be okay
community
oh here's another one
yeah it's always good to have a backup
stream
here's a Pittsburgh
channel do they have what it takes to
represent the people of Pennsylvania is
it starting
[Music]
okay so this may be starting in which
case we are going to be looking at it
very very strongly thanks to Trish
Thompson Lori Kiefer and Alex Adams for
signing up on my website as well as
Stephen Carlson and Iris Nat very much
appreciate all of you the debate starts
very very soon and of course we will
have wall-to-wall coverage of the debate
memberships are aggressively dumping in
Dennis Owens whdm political reporter and
anchor here in Harrisburg along with
Lisa Sylvester from WPXI oh God the
audio will moderate
it's on their end so hopefully they will
fix it
voters can watch this debate in all 67
Pennsylvania counties on nine television
stations serving the Commonwealth before
we get started let's go over tonight's
rules Mr fetterman Mr Oz you will have
60 seconds to answer each question if
there's a follow-up question or rebuttal
you will have up to 30 seconds each
candidate will also have 90 seconds for
a closing statement when your time is up
you'll hear this Bell
gentlemen thank you for being here let's
see if this audio problem is fixed here
Dennis and Lisa there we go
thank you Leland good evening candidates
who moments ago just met for the first
time we're happy to have you here
Welcome to our audience watching at home
on air online and on news nation and we
encourage everyone who is watching
tonight to share your thoughts on social
media remember to use the hashtag PA
Senate debate and you may notice these
large monitors that are behind us this
is part of our closed captioning system
it was requested by John fetterman to
help him process the questions that we
are asking him tonight and approved by
both campaigns and both candidates can
see the monitors one of the screens will
show only the questions being asked
tonight the second screen will caption
the questions and responses from them at
odds we have live experienced captioners
in studio to ensure we are as accurate
as possible in what's sure to be a
fast-paced program and just to know for
those of you using closed captioning at
home the captions you see are not tied
to the captions that the candidates will
see here tonight thank you Lisa with
that let's get started Mr fetterman
we're going to begin with you your
political experience includes serving as
the mayor of Braddock a small Borough
near Pittsburgh and one term as
lieutenant governor you're running for a
seat that could decide the balance of
power in Washington what qualifies you
to be a U.S senator you have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody
I'm running to serve Pennsylvania he's
running to use Pennsylvania here's a man
that spent more than 20 million dollars
of his own money to try to buy that seat
I'm also having to talk about something
called the Oz rule that if he's on TV
he's lying he did that during his career
on his TV show he's done that during his
campaign about lying about
our record here and he's also lying
probably during this debate and let's
also talk about the elephant in the room
I had a stroke he's never let me forget
that
and I might miss some words during this
debate mush two words together but it
knocked me down but I'm going to keep
coming back up and this campaign is all
about to me is about fighting for
everyone in Pennsylvania that ever got
knocked down that needs to get back up
and fighting for all forgotten
communities all across Pennsylvania that
also got knocked down that needs to keep
get back up thank you very much Mr
Federer Mr Oz you are a doctor a
businessman and television personality
but this is your first run for elected
office what qualifies you to be a U.S
senator from Pennsylvania you have 60
seconds I'm running for the U.S Senate
because Washington keeps getting it
wrong with extreme positions I want to
bring civility balance all the things
that you want to see because you've been
telling it to me on the campaign Trail
and by doing that we can bring us
together in a way that has not been done
of late Democrats Republicans talking to
each other John fetterman takes
everything to an extreme and those
extreme positions hurt us all let's take
crime as an example because it's been
such a big problem
Maureen Faulkner accompanied me today to
the studio you know that her husband was
a police officer in Philadelphia he was
brutally murdered John fetterman during
this crime wave has been trying to get
as many murderers convicted and
sentenced to life in prison out of jail
as possible including people who are
similar to the man who murdered her
husband he does it without the the rest
of the parole board agreeing he's doing
it without the families on board these
radical positions extend beyond crime to
one thing to legalize all drugs to open
the Border uh to raising our taxes I
want Washington to be civil again well
you need it to be less radical John
Federer guys I'm not making a joke Oz
didn't have a stroke and he seems to be
making less sense than fetterman minions
are struggling to put food on the table
and gas in their cars our next star
Emerson College the hill poll shows the
economy inflation are the biggest
concerns for voters 39 of them listed
that as the top issue beginning with you
Mr Oz you have blamed President Biden
and Reckless Democratic spending for the
inflation crisis but voters would like
to hear your specific plan to cut
spending please explain in 60 seconds
well if you asked the U.S government
they'll tell you they have four percent
waste and fraud now I've traveled over
the Commonwealth and spoken to countless
people there was a lady in Beaver County
at a County Fair who told me with fear
in our heart that she wanted to provide
food for her son's highly nutritious
chicken she wanted she couldn't afford
it anymore that's a big problem if we've
got four percent waste and fraud we
ought to be take to be able to take care
of that John fetterman's however
response continually is to raise taxes
he raised taxes as mayor he tried to
raise taxes as a lieutenant governor 46
percent that's a big tax rate he
supported Joe Biden's recent tax rate
increase and he's done that without
paying his own taxes 67 times I'll say
that again he hasn't paid his own taxes
67 times but he's raising mine in yours
so it's a radical position they're
extreme they're out of touch with the
values of pennsylvanians and I can make
the difficult decisions as you do in the
operating room as a surgeon I'll make
them cutting our budget as well to make
sure we don't have to raise taxes on a
population already desperately in pain
from the high inflation rate missed
I will allow 15 second rebuttal he has
specifically said you have not paid your
taxes that you want to raise
on Americans how do you respond
absolutely the Oz rule of course he's
lying it was helping two students 17
years ago to help them you know buy
their own homes they they didn't pay the
bills and it got her paid and it has
never been an issue in in any of the
campaign before
it was all about non-profit
thank you Mr fetterman continuing with
you Mr fetterman your opponent has
criticized Democratic spending as you
heard has the Biden Administration
overspent and if so where do you think
spending should be cut you have 60
Seconds
no here's what I think we have to fight
about inflation here right now that's
what we need to fight about inflation
you know right now because it's a tax on
Working Families you know and Dr Oz
can't possibly understand what that is
like you know he has 10 gigantic
Mansions you know he we must push back
against corporate greed we must make
sure that we're also pushing back
against price gouging as well too you
know we also be able to make more in
Pennsylvania make more in America when
he had a choice to make his merchandise
the Oz label is on he made it all in
China you know who can you believe that
can fight against inflation and pushing
back against corporate greed or somebody
that has chosen working in China
versus over
American workers all right I will allow
a 15 second rebuttal to his comments
that you have been making things in
China Mr Oz I've been trying to talk
about policy issues with the people of
Pennsylvania as a doctor I listened to
their ideas and I want to talk about
them when John fetterman brings up
houses the irony is he didn't pay for
his own house he got it for a dollar
from his sister and he hasn't been able
to earn a living on his own he's lived
off his parents so it doesn't it's not a
topic that we should be debating on the
stage we should be talking about crime
and inflation the issues that are
hurting pennsylvanians that they're
talking about at their kitchen table
that's it he got is Pennsylvania from
his own inlays from a dollar we have to
continue on we'll continue on with the
question a follow-up question to you Mr
Oz this one is just for you you tweeted
in August that you will never stop
fighting to lower gas prices for
pennsylvanians does that include
supporting a suspension of the federal
gas tax you have 30 seconds I'm
supportive of reducing taxes but we want
to be thoughtful about the long-term
game plan to get gas taxes down and
frankly all energy prices down I have
gone around the Commonwealth I've
witnessed people say I'm not going on
vacation this year because I can't
afford to pay to take my trailer to the
campground they can't even get there
what we have to do is ensure that we
don't have increased inflation and the
best way to do that is reduce gas prices
John fetterman has gone after the energy
industry called it a stain on
Pennsylvania and argued we have to ban
fracking that is a disconnected from
Pennsylvania thank you thank you Mr Oz
we will get to the issue of fracking
later on in this discussion but meantime
turning back to you Mr fetterman for a
follow-up
in an op-ed for the Wilkes-Barre Times
Leader you wrote quote it is time we
crack down on the big price gouging
corporations that are making record
profits while jacking up prices for all
of us how do you plan to do this sir you
mentioned price going after price
gouging corporations how do you plan to
do this you have 30 seconds yeah exactly
we have to keep pushing back on that and
he would never make that choice to fight
for uh for it for uh Amer families here
in Pennsylvania you know he has never
met an air an oil company that he
doesn't swipe right about you know he
has never been able to stand up for
Working Families all across Pennsylvania
you know we must push back inflation has
hurt Americans and Pennsylvania's
families and it has given the oil
companies record profits all right thank
you Mr fetterman turning to the next
issue Dennis the minimum wage in
Pennsylvania and at the national level
currently sits at seven dollars 25 cents
an hour and has not been increased since
2009. God I mean imagine if what it
takes for you to win if your Oz is your
opponent having a stroke I mean it's
just it this is it's just bad all-around
in so many different ways at 8.75 but
Pennsylvania has not followed suit the
first question is for you Mr fetterman
do you support raising the federal
minimum wage to 15 an hour why or why
not you have 60 seconds yeah I do
absolutely I think it's a disgrace at
7.25 an hour and how can a man you know
with with you know 10 gigantic Mansions
you know has and willing to talk about a
willing wage for anybody imagine a
signal Mom trying with two children
trying to race with them realizing
making Thirty one thousand dollars a
year you know fifteen dollars an hour
you know I believe every work has
dignity and every paycheck must have
dignity in it as well true I've always
supported a living wage and we make sure
that everyone has Economic Security I've
okay follow-up for you Mr fetterman what
better you say better to small business
owners who have told us that if the
minimum wage were increased to 15 an
hour it would put them out of business
you have 30 seconds
now we we all have to make sure that
everyone that works is able to that's
that's the most American bargain that if
you work full-time you should be able to
live in dignity as well true and I
believe they haven't have any businesses
being being uh
you can't have businesses being
subsidized by not paying individuals
that just simply can't behave to that's
their own way okay when they pay to keep
wages the state is just subsidized I
mean he's a hundred percent right to 15
an hour why or why not you have 60
seconds I think Market forces have
already driven up the minimum wage I was
with a hotel worker actually here in
Harrisburg a few months ago and he was
telling me how hard it was to live on
the 15 an hour that he was getting paid
John Federman shoots too low we want
much more money than that and there are
many ways to achieve that but John
fetterman thinks the minimum wages is
weekly allowance from his parents he's
not really cognizant of the real
challenges of business owners who've got
to balance that with employees
thankfully we have a solution and John
you didn't answer the question you can't
put businesses out of uh Commission in
order to pay more wages because they
won't be the wages will go to zero which
is John federman's radical Planet if you
really follow to conclusion here's what
I would do we have one of the richest
energy states in the country I believe
if we can unleash the energy beneath our
feet here in Pennsylvania there'd be
plenty of money to go around we'd have
increased wages a more reason for
students to take uh well take vocational
classes to be able to learn trades which
I'm strongly supportive of we'd also be
able to pipe that gas and pre improve
our economy and reduce inflation that's
a plan that works and it's humble enough
that I can say broadly thank you I want
to I want to give you uh Mr fetterman a
15 second follow-up to what he just said
about you again it's it's remarkable he
hasn't really had any answer that he
actually had about that in his he
doesn't want to talk about having
somebody having a living wage and having
somebody able to survive again and I
want to come back to you now Mr Oz for a
quick follow-up what do you say to those
pennsylvanians that he just spoke of
that are trying to survive on 725 an
hour Which is less than all of our
neighbors you have 30 seconds oh I don't
think you should have to survive on 725
an hour I want the minimum wage up as
high as it can go I want to highlight
that I have an agenda for Prosperity
unlike John fetterman I want us all
getting paid a lot more than fifteen
dollars and I answered your question
directly in a way that would preserve
business owners job creators so they
Thrive and we'd have lots more employees
entering the workforce and then
prospering getting paid 25 35 45 an hour
but we're never going to get there if
you don't unleash our energy and John
fetterman's stubbornness on calling it a
stain on Pennsylvania is an insult to
those workers so be clear you said you
want people making a lot more but that's
not through a federal law of minimum
wage that's through Market forces should
drive it up anyway and it's already done
that thank you you know you should be
able to get paid much more than fifteen
dollars all right thank you gentlemen
another big issue for voters is abortion
Mr Oz we will begin with you you say
that you're pro-life but you do support
abortion exceptions in the cases of rape
incest and to protect the life of the
mother aside from those three exceptions
should abortion be banned in America 60
seconds there should not be involved
open from the federal government and how
States decide their abortion decisions
as a physician I've been in the room
when there's some difficult
conversations happening I don't want the
federal government involved with that at
all I want women doctors local political
leaders letting the Democracy that's
always allowed our nation to thrive to
put the best ideas forward so states can
decide for themselves contrast that with
my opponent John Federman who on this
debate stage said that he would demand
federally mandated rules for all states
they'd have to follow that would allow
abortion at 38 weeks on the delivery
table and he would force it to be
subsidized by taxpayers across the
country no matter what their personal
beliefs are that's radical that's
extreme that is out of touch with what
the average voter in Pennsylvania
believes is appropriate now ironically
John fedem has been running ads on this
topic dishonest ads I need to correct
the record they were so bad they got
pulled off television stations I've got
they've been on this station that he was
running dishonest ads that I had pulled
off I haven't had a single ad pulled
down my ads tell the truth John
fettermans are a fiction of his
imagination all right I'm going to let
Mr fetterman respond specifically about
the ads being pulled off the air and
then we will return to you Mr Oz Mr
fetterman yeah I want to look into the
face of every woman in Pennsylvania you
know if you believe that the choice of
your reproductive Freedom belongs with
Dr Oz then you have a choice but if you
believe that the choice for abortion
belongs between you and your doctor
that's what I fight for Roe v Wade for
me is should be the law he celebrated
when Roe v Wade went down and my
campaign would fight for Roe v Wade and
if given the opportunity to codify it
into law
the really tough thing about this is
it's so obvious that fetterman is not
even remotely cognitively affected he
remembers every detail every fact about
what Oz has said but it's the struggle
to turn it into language in the fluid
and coherent way that he wants to be
able to before if the vote were held
today you were elected Senator you're on
the senate floor the clerk calls you
there's a roll call vote are you a yay
or an A how would you vote on the
Lindsey Graham bill you have 30 seconds
Lisa I don't even need 30 seconds I'll
give you a bigger answer I am not going
to support Federal Federal rules that
block the ability of states to do what
they wish to do the abortion decision
should be left up the states and
specifically when John ferryman won with
Doug mostrion
you'll have your turn John one moment Mr
fetterman continue I've been very clear
on my desire as a physician not to
interfere with how States decide so when
John purposely knowingly misrepresents
that women he scares is them he's
purposely trying to alarm them and the
fear-mongering isn't working running
tens of millions of dollars of ads
claiming that I'm against all abortions
when he knows that's not right claiming
that I'm going to be strict with
Pennsylvania where he knows that's not
honest I can't be any clearer that I've
been on the stage today John fedema if
you just hear that one story today I'd
be really happy but I know you're not
going to because you're going to go
right back to telling the fables that
you believe Mr Oz I want a 15 second
clarification you are saying that you
would leave it up to the states of the
federal government does not have a role
here so are you saying you would not
vote for the Lindsey Graham Bill any
bill that violates what I said which is
the federal government's interfering
with the state Rule and abortion I would
vote against what I feel strongly about
is that women in Pennsylvania understand
what I'm saying and not believe that
someone who's taking an extreme position
like John Friedman represents them
because most women do not believe that
we should at a federal level codify 38
weeks of uh permission to have an
abortion and have taxpayers pay for it
so yes or no on the Lindsey Graham think
I've answered this very clearly three
times okay all right thank you Mr Oz
turning to you Mr fetterman
you safe and legal
when a woman can have an abortion please
explain in 60 seconds you know what I
support I support on Roe v Wade that was
the law of the land for 50 years he
celebrated when it fell down and I would
fight to re-establish on Roe v wait
that's what I run on that's what I
believe and I've always believed that
the choice believes women and their
doctors and he believes that the choice
to be with him or republican legislators
all across this nation all right I'm
sorry I must correct that once again
he's misrepresented what I've said but
he also said something very dishonest on
this debate stage he said very
specifically in his primary debate when
he was still debating that he would
support 38 weeks of mandated Rules by
the federal government that would
prevent any state from blocking it so
that's not that's not true I support Roe
v Wade that's the simple John you said
specifically you would support a federal
rule in 38 weeks thank you thank you I
think it's important that John at least
acknowledge that he's not honest here
because you said
we must continue on Mr fetterman turning
to you we have a follow-up question
would you support allocating federal
funds to transport women who live in
states where abortion is banned to
states where they can get one and why 30
seconds
I would I would because I believe
abortion rights is a universal right for
all women in America I believe that it I
believe abortion is health care and I
believe that that is a choice that
belongs with each woman and their doctor
all right thank you Mr Mr fetterman
turning to the next issue Dennis Thank
you Lisa let's turn to what has become
one of the key themes of this race
Fitness to serve for these individual
questions there will be no rebuttals
allowed Mr fetterman we begin with you
you suffered as you mentioned a moment
ago a stroke four days before the May
primary last week you released this note
from your doctor saying you can work
full Duty in public office but you have
not released your detailed medical
records surrounding your stroke Mr
fetterman will you pledge tonight to
release those records in the interest of
transparency you have 60 seconds no uh
three for transparency is about showing
up I'm here today to have a debate I
have you know speeches in front of 3 000
people in Montgomery County you know all
across Pennsylvania big big crowds you
know I believe if my doctor believes
that I'm fit to serve and and that's
what I believe is appropriate and now
with two weeks before the election you
know I have run the campaign and I've
been very transparent about being very
open about the fact we're in news
captioning and I believe that again my
doctors the real doctors that I believe
and they all believe that I'm ready to
be served follow up I didn't hear you
say you would release your full medical
records why not you have 30 seconds
now uh yeah again my Dr L believes that
I'm fit to be serving and that's what I
believe is where I'm standing okay Mr
fetterman thank you Mr Oz you have built
a lucrative career around medicine but
you've been criticized even by some
fellow Physicians for promoting quote
unproven ill-advised and at times
potentially dangerous treatments what is
your response to that you have 60
seconds one of the great blessings of
traveling around Pennsylvania is you run
into people who have watched the show
they thank me very much for giving them
life-saving advice on chronic issues
like high blood pressure or dealing with
their anxiety the show did very well
because it provided high quality
information that empowered people which
was I was exactly what I want to do
drinking silver give people the power
let them make decisions for their
well-being now John fetterman's approach
to health is a very dangerous one he
believes we should socialize medicine he
embraced this with Bernie Sanders who
endorsed the two candidates call
themselves The two most Progressive
people in America when you have
socialized medicine they as you shut
down the ability of people to get access
to health care doctors stop practicing
there are no medications available the
lines get long it's a disaster and it
puts people at risk so I don't believe
we should allow socialized medicine the
abolition of all Private health care
insurance in America and and radical
positions like the ones taken by John
fetterman making too extreme to serve if
we're going to bring balance to
Washington you got to bring people who
understand the ramifications even Joe
Biden even Joe Biden called John
federman's idea I'll quote him
Preposterous Mr fetterman I'm going to
let you respond in just a minute but I
have a follow-up for you first Mr Oz did
you or your company make a profit from
promoting those products you have 30
seconds I never sold weight loss
products as as I never sold this it's a
it's a television show like this is a
television show people I never sold on
the shows and that's a perfectly
appropriate and very transparent
dishonest I ruffled a lot of feathers on
my show because I told people the truth
and I'm proud of that I'll do the exact
same thing as a US senator but the okay
but but there's there's there's no way
to defend what John fetterman has done
with socialized medicine that is a
radical departure from what we in
America have accepted the relationship
between you John you'll have your turn
John
there must be a relationship between a
doctor and a patient and that's what I
would direct patients to do thank you Mr
fetterman he accused you of socialized
medicine supporting socialized medicine
what is your response again again it's
the odds rule he's on TV and he's lying
I've never so I never supported any of
that thing you know he keeps talking
about Bernie Bernie Sanders you know
three years three years ago he was on
his show and he hugged him and he said I
love this guy you know what why don't
you pretend that you you live in Vermont
instead of Pennsylvania and run against
Bernie Sanders because all you can do is
talk about Bernie Sanders because my
truth is is that Healthcare is a basic
fundamental right and I believe in
expanding that and I believe about
supporting fighting for Health Care the
kind of Health Care that saved my life
for goodness that was dishonest he is
explicitly supported social media we
have a lot of topics to get to I think
Lisa you go ahead we are going to move
on to the next topic and this has come
up earlier and that is the issue of
fracking Pennsylvania only Trails Texas
in terms of natural gas production both
of you have taken shifting positions on
the issue of fracking Mr Oz we begin
with you
you wrote a column in 2014 calling for
no fracking pending health study results
but in a video posted on social media in
March you said quote natural gas
guarantees high-paying skill jobs right
here in Pennsylvania so back off Biden
give us freedom to Frack Mr Oz please
explain that changing position 60
seconds I've been very consistent
fracking has been demonstrated it's a
very old technology to be safe it is a
Lifeline for this Commonwealth to be
able to build wealth similar to what
they've been able to achieve in other
states for that reason I strongly
support fracking drilling the piping of
that natural gas in fact I built a
facility even in Philadelphia so we can
export it oh my God to our allies and
help them the ones that are struggling
now in eastern and western Europe
because of the Ukrainian War John
Federman calls fracking a stain on
Pennsylvania he says that he was signed
a moratorium to ban its continued use he
he's against pipelines he voted him are
supported the vote against the Keystone
Pipeline that ended up shutting it down
he supports by Oz isn't particularly
coherent either I must say and all of
our lands together this is this is a
extreme position on energy if we
unleashed our energy here in
Pennsylvania it would help everybody why
John Federman is so rigidly stuck on
fighting about against energy companies
is stunning to me because it's the jobs
I want tens of thousands of high-paying
jobs to help Pennsylvania thank you Mr
Osmond Oz rule Mr fetterman I absolutely
support fracking in fact I live across
the street from the steel mill and they
were going to frac to create their own
energy in order to make them more
competitive and I support that living
closer to anybody else in Pennsylvania
for fracking to myself I believe that we
need independence with energy and I
believe I've walked that line my entire
career I believe Democrats Mr Mr
fetterman I do have a specific question
which you can continue on this topic but
you have made two conflicting statements
regarding fracking in a 2018 interview
you said quote I don't support fracking
at all I never have but earlier this
month you told an interviewer quote I
support fracking I support the energy
Independence that we should have here in
the United States so Mr fetterman please
explain your changing position 60
seconds
yeah I I I've I've always supported
fracking and I always believe that
independence with our energy is is
critical or we can't be held you know
you know Ransom to somebody like Russia
you know I've always believed that
energy Independence is critical and I've
always believed that and I do support
fracking I've never taken any money from
their their their industry but I support
how critical it is that we produce our
own energy and create energy
Independence I must correct the record
just a second welcome to everybody from
trihex joining us you're saying tonight
that you support fracking that you've
always supported fracking but there is
that 2018 interview that you said quote
I don't support fracking at all so how
do you square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking okay thank you Mr
fetterman Andre Lisa there's not just a
statement you read There are multiples
pictures of him we have to go we have to
move on but we have to get the
fundamentals of the truth out here John
we have a lot of time took positions
against energy we have a lot of topics
you will have a chance to have that you
may want one comment then the energy
Industries houses
we want to now turn to Public Safety Mr
fetterman Republicans have called you
dangerously soft on crime the
Pennsylvania State Troopers Association
has endorsed Democrat Josh Shapiro for
governor but in this race it endorsed
your Republican opponent Mr Oz what is
your response to those endorsements and
what is your response to accusations
that you are quote dangerously soft on
crime you have 60 seconds
now I I I I believe that I run on my
record on crime you know I ran to be
mayor back in 2005 in order to fight gun
violence and that's exactly what I did
in working with the police and working
with our community I would say I was
able to stop gun violence for five and a
half years as mayor ever accomplished
before or since my time as as mayor
because I'm the only person on this
stage right now that has con it can is
successful about pushing back against
gun violence and being the community
more safe you know all he's done is just
put a plan up on his website in the last
24 hours he has no experience he has
never made any attempt to try to address
crime during his entire career except
showing up for photo ops here in
Philadelphia I will give you 15 seconds
to respond to that and then I have a
question for you the Fraternal Order of
Police from Braddock the small town he
represented endorsed me they supported
me because what he's saying is not not
true violence skyrocketed and Braddock I
mean the town wasn't in a good shape
when John got there it got worse when he
was there people kept leaving so of
course you're going to have uh you know
all kinds of bear aberrations but John
the city was dangerous under your
leadership and that's right Mr Oz this
past summer Congress passed the first
gun control bill in decades that would
not have happened without the support of
the man you are running to replace Pat
Toomey how would you have voted on that
bill and would you continue toomey's
Legacy as being one of the lead
republicans in Congress on pushing for
gun reforms you have 60 seconds
I have been supported by Pat Toomey I've
enjoyed working with him I think he's
done a wonderful job there are parts of
that bill that I like a lot for example
I like the fact that their background
checks that are being strengthened now
so we can make sure that people who
should not have guns don't get guns I
also like the fact that there was a lot
of money invested for mental health
which is an important part of the
equation I've been to Philadelphia I've
done prayer vigils with black clergy
leaders who are desperately trying to
save the people in their Community half
the murders in Philadelphia are
committed by people under 18 we have got
to get Mental Health Services to these
people and it's not happening now but
part of the problem is that we have
taken away the ability of police to do
their job and that's on John fetterman
because John Federman has taken such a
harsh position against them he's
undermined them at every level taking
away some of their funding he's pushed
for krasner who he admires tremendously
he's spoken highly of him just this week
he's taken his policies to a new extreme
he argued that people should be let out
of jail without any Bill no matter what
they did to get in there he's argued to
release one-third of all prisoners
one-third of all prisoners come out of
touch quickly 15 seconds would you have
voted for that Pat Toomey supported bill
I would have tried to improve that bill
there are things that I think most of us
appreciate I wasn't there at the time so
I can't speak to what was possible but I
do know there are parts of that bill
that do make sense and the ones I
described should be followed let's see
how it works out okay thank you Lisa on
to our next issue and that is illegal
immigration it has been a problem in the
United States for decades but it is now
spiking U.S Customs and Border
Protection just released numbers from
fiscal year 2022 they show more than 2.7
million total enforcement actions in the
well better numbers than our YouTube
Subs Mr Oz beginning with you Republican
governors in the South have been sending
migrants to democratic run cities and
states without a plan or without any
coordination it is certainly gaining a
lot of attention but is it an effective
way to deal with the influx of migrants
you have 60 Seconds Lisa we have a
catastrophe at the border and we should
not have Sanctuary cities as John
fetterman has tried to introduce but
I've been into the parts of Philadelphia
and Allentown and reading where we have
large Latino populations I understand
the challenges of the of the Border my
father was an immigrant my mother were
immigrants you know I understand what
legal immigration offers us but the
completely porous open nature of our
border which John Federman supports has
created a humanitarian crisis with
cartels profiting with human trafficking
operations they take the money they buy
narcotics from China and bring that into
our country and it's making every state
a border state Pennsylvania is already a
border state because we're a top three
in the country and Fentanyl overdoses at
least I can't go anywhere where and
giving any big event where I don't meet
multiple people who say their personal
lives have been destroyed because of
fentanyl overdoses yet John Federman not
only wants an open border not only
supports Sanctuary cities but he wants
to legalize all hard drugs in America
including narcotics that is
I mean out of touch with everybody that
radical position was tried in Oregon
which he endorsed 50 homicide increase
rate one moment I will give a 15 second
rebuttal yeah that that is again as rule
that is just not true uh you know yeah
here his his family's company was it was
levied the largest fine for immigration
hiring of of of immigrant uh illegals
you know and I think you should sit this
one out about in terms of what a sore a
secure border all right we do have a
follow-up specifically for you Mr
fetterman Vice President Kamala Harris
says the southern border border is
secure yet we are seeing an
unprecedented number of migrants
Crossing is the border secure and if not
what would you do to fix what both
parties are calling a crisis you have 60
seconds Mr fetterman
you know I believe that I believe that a
secure border is can be compatible with
compassion I believe we need a
comprehensive and bipartisan solution
for immigration that's what I believe I
don't ever recall in the Statue of
Liberty that they say you know you know
take our tired huddle masses and put
them on a bus and use cheap political
stunts about them I believe we have to
develop a comprehensive and bicartisan
solution to to address our issue here
for immigration here in our nation all
right thank you gentlemen Johnson
addressing the elephant in the room we
have to move on to the next issue we
will
turning now to foreign policy Mr
fetterman what do you believe is the
greatest foreign threat to the United
States of America you have 60 Seconds
I believe I I believe you know is is
right now is is China I believe China is
not our friend and I believe that we
can't be able to push back and we need
to stand against China and I believe
that Dr Oz has chosen to manufacture all
of his merchandise on his name on it in
China which one of us on this stage is
going to stand up against and stand firm
against China you know and I believe
that's our single biggest issue right
now to make sure that we address China
and make sure that we know that it's not
our friend Mr Oz what do you believe is
the greatest foreign threat to the
United States of America you have 60
seconds the fact that our country is not
projecting strength take for example
what we're doing with Iran in order to
try to get them to give us a little oil
so we can deal with the catastrophe that
Russia has caused we have gone to them
and tried to sign a deal that would
allow them once again to have the
nuclear power to blow up Israel which
they promised they would do John
Federman supports that deal it doesn't
make any sense for America to treat our
enemies better than our allies we have
the message with our strong voice and
the energy we have in our country that
we have control over our future and the
best way for America to establish its
dominance is to unleash the energy here
in Pennsylvania and across the country
by not doing that not only do we cause
all kinds of problems with local jobs
and inflation but we're destroying our
ability to remain energy dominant and
we're not able to become allies like we
should be for countries like European
nations which are going to struggle
their with their Coldest Winter Ever
it's the best way to punch Putin back
and to teach China lesson is American
Energy to reign supreme and John
fetterman doesn't like American Energy
and they are scared of him because they
know they can't trust them he's proven
what Mr Ross Thank you Lisa all right to
on to our next issue in our recent next
star poll a hypothetical rematch between
Joe Biden and Donald Trump in 2024 would
be a statistical tie in Pennsylvania
46 percent of people said they would
vote for former president Trump what is
wrong 45 for President Biden Mr Oz would
you support a trump 2024 run and why 60
seconds I'll support whoever the
Republican Party puts up and I have
reached out who watched the aisle on my
campaign because I want to bring balance
to it I tried to work with Democrats and
Republicans and people in the middle and
people unsure and people who forgotten
people who got angry with where their
party was headed I want to bring us
together to make this country do what
it's always been able to do unify not
divide and address the problems as a
surgeon because in the or that's what I
do I just fix the big problem in Front
of Me John fetterman however cannot go
to Washington and work with the other
side because he doesn't even get along
with his own side he criticized Joe
Biden for not spending enough money and
not settling up close enough to Bernie
Sanders he says he won't work with Joe
manchin he said if you vote if you like
Joe manchin don't vote for me how does
this relate to the question does anybody
know gonna be able to reach across the
aisle to the other side his extreme
positions have made it untenable for
Republican lawmakers we need to send
someone to Washington who understands
the importance of balance sensible
decision making and in common sense
approach to the challenges that we all
face that's not John fetterman Mr Oz
Donald Trump has supported you he has
endorsed you why won't you fully commit
to supporting him in 2024. okay oh I do
I would support Donald Trump if he
decided to run for president all right
but this is bigger than one candidate
this is something about how we are going
to build a bigger tent to let more
Americans feel safe are you concerned
about the ongoing legal investigations
involving the former president 32nd sir
I haven't followed them very carefully
I've been campaigning pretty
aggressively they'll work themselves out
I have tremendous confidence in the
American legal system and I believe law
and order will reign supreme but
speaking about that topic there's one
person on this stage who's broken the
law We Believe John fetterman took a
shotgun chased a unarmed
African-American man and put the gun
apparently according to that man to his
chest John you weren't pulled over by
the police they let you go you were the
mayor at the time why haven't you
apologized to that unarmed innocent
black man who you put a shotgun to his
chest all right we will allow a
30-second response to that Mr fetterman
specifically what he was saying
referring to the incident attic I I made
the opportunity to defend my community
as the chief law enforcement officer
there everybody in Braddock an
overwhelmingly majority community of of
black uh Community all understood what
happened you know they they understood
what happened and everybody agreed that
and nobody believes that it was anything
about me making a split second decision
to to defend our community as well why
not apologize uh Mr Oz please uh we are
still with Mr fetterman turning to you
right now you support a Biden run do you
support a Biden run in 2024 why in 60
Seconds
uh that's honestly it's up to his choice
whether he you know and if he does
choose to run I would absolutely support
him but ultimately that's ultimately
only his choice all right thank you Mr
fetterman a fall in a fashion on this
our next star poll shows 51 of
Pennsylvania voters disapprove of the
president's job performance you have
publicly supported many of his policy
positions are there any that you
disagree with 30 seconds
no I just believe he needs to do more
about supporting uh and fighting about
in inflation uh and I I do believe he
can do more about that but uh at the end
of the day I think Joe Biden is a good
good family man and I believe he stands
for the union way of life and I believe
that employment unemployment is already
down to the lowest level in the last 50
years all right thank you gentlemen
Dennis let's turn now gentlemen to the
issue of Social Security it is only
fully funded through 2034. many
Americans are worried that they will
never receive their full benefit or have
to accept cuts to their benefits Mr
fetterman how are you going to make sure
it is there for them you have 60 seconds
we need to make sure that Dr Oz and the
Republicans Believe In cutting Medicare
and Social Security and I believe that
they have to support and expand Social
Security and if somebody sends me to
send me to Washington DC I would support
and stand and to support security uh
Social Security okay thank you Mr Roz
same question to you how are you going
to make sure that Social Security is
available for future Americans you have
60 seconds we made a deal with the
wonderful seniors of our nation they
worked their hearts out they paid into a
program no one's going to touch it on my
watch except to make sure that it's
stronger than it is right now Social
Security Medicare which I know a lot
about as a doctor are the fundamental uh
element of security for our seniors and
they deserve to feel like their value by
our nation John fetterman again has been
running ads and saying that I'm against
those with no proof I have never said
anything different than what I'm saying
to you on this stage but in an effort to
fear-monger with people who are older
and can be taken advantage of he'll run
these ads John it's reprehensible but
it's also reflective of your approach to
doing these things you haven't shown up
on the campaign Trail you haven't
answered questions from voters not once
on the campaign Trail you haven't
answered questions from media once in
the campaign Trail even you know just to
show off as you can do it and this is
the only debate I could get you to come
to talk to me on and I had to beg on my
knees to get you to come and if it
wasn't for Dennis probably getting
involved I don't think it would have
happened look seniors need to know more
about your radical left positions and I
need to be able to tell them about my
positions that's what democracy is built
on we exchange ideas the voters decide
you have hidden from Mr Oz I'm going to
let you have 15 seconds in a moment Mr
fetterman but can you give us a specific
example of what you would do to protect
Social Security well for one we have to
make sure that it adequately increases
with the higher inflation rates that we
have so we've got to make that four
percent
right now it's in the budget uh
redirected appropriately and one of the
first places that I would use it is
social security does Oz know anything
what are the worst things we can do to a
people is give them bad quality uh care
and so if you have
if you have people who are not going to
see a doctor for example because they
can't afford it they'll get sicker Bad
Medicine means more cost no one benefits
thank you Mr fetterman he said a few
things a moment ago I want to give you
15 seconds to respond to those
no again I just can't I can't just say
one thing other than that Dr Oz would
not support and he would support cutting
Medicare and that's John why do you say
that I've never said that it's
absolutely a fact it's a fact you would
have voted against the the inflation
reduction act which has dropped our
prescription drugs and he doesn't Okay
gentlemen we need to move on Lisa all
right we are moving on to the topic of
Education the cost of college tuition is
now Out Of Reach for many many families
our question is for both of you we start
with Mr Oz what is your plan to bring
down the cost of higher education long
term you have one minute Mr Oz I worked
in an academic medical centers my whole
life so I'm in higher education and I
can tell you the reason the prices have
gone up six-fold in the last 40 years is
not because the education quality is
better we've added extra extra layers of
middle middle level individuals who
don't actually improve the quality
education in my opinion there's a lot of
expenses that now incurred by these
institutions and it's not right for the
American people to be stuck with the
bill I would push them to offer more
electronic classes half the kids don't
live on campus anyway John fetterman's
approach however is not to deal with the
unnecessarily high costs but just to pay
it so if you want to pay students who
didn't pay their loans back basically
what John fetterman and Joe Biden are
are arguing for is for plumbers who
didn't go to college and couldn't for a
bunch of reasons afford it to pay the
bills of lawyers who went to graduate
school and haven't paid their debt back
I don't think that's right for the
American people we want a fair system
dropped the cost down by pushing for
more Dr Oz is about to take a defiant
and principled stance against plumber's
crack when they graduate all right I
will allow a 15 second rebuttal
specifically on the issue of student
loan debt which Mr Oz was referring to
Mr fetterman again Dr Oz you know loves
free free money when it's a half a
million dollar tax break on one of his
you know homes down in a ranch in
Florida and whether it was a 50 tax
break you know about his farm in
Montgomery County so it's about
supporting and helping you know young
earners excuse me young
young uh
young you know students to to give them
a break I believe that
that supporting uh all right let me just
ask specifically Mr fetterman five
seconds please address his foreign
policy positions of ten thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars per Pell Grant
recipients do you support that position
I I do absolutely support that I believe
like I said uh it's about helping Young
Learners you know be able to get a
better start you know getting off in the
start of their life and I I do believe
that and I believe a majority of
Americans support that as well too
helping helping young Young Learners all
right Mr fetterman I want to ask you the
same question that I asked Mr Oz and
what is your plan to bring down the cost
of higher education long term you have
one minute
yeah I don't think he he didn't answer
he didn't answer the the question
whatsoever
I believe Charles please give him a
moment no you didn't
i i i fundamentally believe that every
quality Public University education
should be very affordable in in every
state and hey I I don't care that you
paid 20 bucks to send your stupid
message Grant you're you're making fun
of people for medical conditions and
you're banned and we get to keep the 20
bucks by the way Pitt or any state
schools to make it much more affordable
and that means inquiring a significant
investment to make sure and create it
affordable that every family can afford
how how exactly Mr fetterman do you
propose doing that to make it more
affordable for a fan for families
no I I just believe I just make we're
selling bands if anybody wants to pay
for a ban I believe providing the
resources to reduce the tuition to allow
families to be able to afford it all
right we have a follow-up follow the
question this one now is for
his first nation viewer Ann Andrews a
registered nurse from conneautville near
Erie and is a vocational educational
instructor for a university and a
practicing registered nurse
if you were elected could you please
tell me what you would be doing for
vocational education in the state of
Pennsylvania as well as our nation
so Mr Oz if elected what would you do
for vocational education you have 30
seconds I visited vocational schools I
have an answer but John because you
obviously I wasn't clear enough for you
to understand this there's no question
that cutting out the middle levels of
higher education and providing digital
programs would reduce the cost of
Education it's a Concrete set of ideas
that I'd like to move on with regard to
vocational education this is really
important for us to allow our trade
unions to get closerly linked more
closely linked with the vocational
schools I was in a vocational school in
Westmoreland and they have about a
thousand kids they could take two
thousand kids funding those programs is
the smartest way to invest our tax
dollars will turn out twice as many
children who have a job as soon as they
graduate it supports our trade unions
want those kids in their positions
anyway that makes the whole program work
thank you Mr Oz Mr fetterman if elected
what would you do for vocational
education you have 30 seconds again I
think it's no it's it's just the same
the way the university four degrees as
well too supporting that and partnering
with the the unions and making sure that
vocation training are is is is
Affordable and providing the resources
to make sure everyone has the
opportunity going to college isn't the
right choice for it for every person you
know but going to those kind of
emotional schools able to create a
career to wait to excuse me to Wayne Uh
rage a lot of uh High salary and again
supporting to reduce those costs are
critical too all right thank you
gentlemen Dennis moving now uh multiple
members of Congress specifically
Democrats have called for the Supreme
Court to be expanded candidates we want
to know where you stand on this Mr
fetterman should the Supreme Court be
expanded and if so by how many justices
you have 60 seconds I I don't believe
I've never I don't stand and I don't
believe in that you know I fundamentally
believe that even though I don't agree
with the ideological breakup of the
Supreme Court you know I believe believe
it's not about changing the rules it's
about
acknowledging where we're at much the
way the Republicans want to try to
change the Constitution about how our
Supreme Court in Pennsylvania was going
to be done and I don't support that so I
think it's it's critical that we be
consistent and I do not believe in
supporting the Supreme Court Mr Ross
same question to you should the Supreme
Court be expanded if so by how many
justices you have 60 seconds I would
never touch the maker of the Supreme
Court and I would Advocate to leave it
the exact same size it is but John
fetterman's radical positions have
spilled over into what he would do in
Washington one of the first things he
has said and he came back to the
campaign Trail is that he wanted to bust
the filibuster which means removing the
the brakes on the Senate overreacting
that's that's true that is that is true
but if you do that then you would free
up the Democrats in the Senate without
getting the normal amount of votes to
actually expand the Supreme Court add
more states do things that are
detrimental to the well-being of the
country so I think and your first day
back arguing that we should get rid of
the filibuster is is a dangerously
radical move that would hurt Washington
it's not in our nation's best interest
thank you both very much all right at
this time this time we are ready for our
closing statements you each have 90
seconds to convince pennsylvanians to
vote for you on Election Day Mr
fetterman you are first 90 seconds
once again I would just like to say that
I my campaign is all about fighting for
anyone in Pennsylvania that ever got
knocked down that had you're getting
blocked no I'm also fighting for any
forgotten Community all across
Pennsylvania they ever got knocked down
that had to be made to get back up and
I've made my entire career dedicating to
those kinds of Pursuits I started as a
GED instructor back in in Braddock over
20 years ago because I believe it's
about serving Pennsylvania not about
using Pennsylvania for their own and
interests as well to me careers are
revealed
uh by your real underlying values and my
values have always been about fighting
for forgotten communities all across
Pennsylvania all right thank you Mr
fetterman Mr Oz your final thoughts 90
seconds
I love traveling to the four corners of
the beautiful Commonwealth and I've
heard your problems I'm a surgeon doctor
I listen to what you say and I'm trying
to help address them today I've talked
to seniors worried their Social Security
checks wouldn't go far enough with the
Raging inflation
I've talked to couples when I make their
first down payment on a new house and
they can't afford it anymore because of
interest rates I've talked to families
you want to cut Social Security Mr
fetterman it's his turn for his closing
oh god I've talked to families worried
about fentanyl showing up in their
mailbox and literally taking the lives
of their children who they find blue in
bed I I've talked to families who won't
let their kids go outside because of the
crime wave that's been facilitated by
left radical policies like the ones John
fetterman has been advocating for but
here's the deal right none of this has
to happen this is all very addressable
I'm a surgeon I'm not a politician how
many times we say big problems we focus
on them and we fix them we do it by
uniting by coming together not dividing
and by doing that we can get ahead but
I've got one question to challenge you
with just one question if you take what
I'm saying to Heart ask yourself this
and others in your family are you
unhappy with where America is headed
I am and if you are as well that I'm the
candidate for change
I'm a living embodiment of the American
dream I believe we're the land of
opportunity to Land of Plenty I believe
we can balance a budget without
recklessly spending I believe we can
have an Unleashed energy policy that
helps us all I believe that we can have
safe city streets and a secure border so
legal immigrants can come across but you
shut the fentanyl out I believe we can
give Parents Choice and where their kids
go to school we can have affordable
health care but most of all I believe in
you and if you can do this together and
we can I would ask for your vote on
election day God bless you we do have
one final question an important issue in
Pennsylvania uh the eyes of the state
are on this debate tonight but on Sunday
they will be on Lincoln Financial Field
in Philadelphia as the state's two NFL
teams go head-to-head Mr fetterman
Steelers or Eagles and why
oh clearly always for the Steelers Mr Oz
I'll be at the game rooting for my
Eagles Fly Eagles Fly gentlemen thank
you both so much this does conclude our
debate we do want to thank our
candidates for being with us Mr
fetterman and Mr Oz and for all of you
at home who have been watching thank you
so much and we want to thank our team at
all right listen guys I'm going to be
very real with everybody
um John fetterman being here just months
after a serious stroke it takes courage
it takes grit it takes determination he
clearly is more knowledgeable on the
issues he clearly would be the better
senator
this was really tough to watch it didn't
look good the Optics weren't good
okay
I would vote for the guy there's no
question whatsoever he clearly has no
cognitive issue he remembers the details
of what Oz said and when he said it
no doubt whatsoever
but sadly because of fetterman's stroke
Oz may win it's one point that separates
them
it's very very sad also not to get all
8th grade teacher on people in the
audience
but what the hell is wrong with some of
you guys and gals
making it's like it's like making fun of
someone for having diabetes or cancer
what is wrong with some of you it's I
I'm honestly I'm wondering what your
day-to-day lives are like I mean
seriously some of the stuff we were
seeing
like what is what is wrong with some of
you
sad maybe yeah maybe you learned it from
Trump I don't know
yeah he really set the tone four year
five years ago yeah
um
I'm not talking about the people who had
no idea
that he had a stroke that's not what I'm
talking about
a thank you to S Prez for dumping in 38
subscriptions and getting us to a
hundred listen folks
the 2022 coverage continues before you
leave if you're watching on YouTube hit
that subscribe button we are pushing
towards 2 million subscriptions look at
these numbers folks oh my God what is
happening
look at this
I feel like I'm in Vegas what is
happening
welcome welcome welcome everybody
like I said before uh almost three
million people watch our videos every
month but don't subscribe I would I
would love for you to subscribe if
you're watching on Twitch make sure to
follow before you leave the the coverage
continues leading up to
live election results on November 8th
for which I hope you all will join me
last thing remember that we are a viewer
and listener supported program I can't
encourage you strongly enough look at
look at these numbers to go to
joinpakman.com and get yourself a
membership okay you can use the coupon
code Obama Obama
it's very cheap we do an extra show
every day for our website members and I
would really love for you to do it
thanks to Robert E for gifting five
subscriptions over on Twitch uh oh do we
want to do hey do you guys want to stick
around I'll I'll quickly do my uh yeah
my colleague John suggested this with
Halloween coming up should I do my
Halloween candy tier list does anybody
care about this or should I just torpedo
the stream and punch myself in the face
the rest of the night what do we think
should I should I do people want me to
do this
all right let's do it all right let's do
our a tier list for Halloween candy 100
Grand 100 Grand isn't great but it's not
terrible I would put it at e
okay
Mounds I'm not I don't dislike mounts I
would put it at C
Three Musketeers I liked as a kid it's
not the best so I would put it as B
hard to beat an Apple so an apple is
definitely s tier let's see what else
we've got anything I haven't heard of
I'm just putting it f so cow tails I've
never heard of
uh uh what else oh candy corn is
absolutely vile I'm putting that at f
Blow Pops or an e
Butterfinger is below a Mounds I give it
a d
um Dums is an e
Fruit by the Foot is a d Haribo Golden
Bears are very good I do like those I
would put these
A or B let me think about that I would
put him as a uh no it's a bit it's like
a Three Musketeers yeah
um okay
Almond Joy I'm a fan but I consider it
equivalent to amounts bottle caps I've
never heard of
uh dots I'm not big on dots
Swiss Miss hot chocolate that just
doesn't really make any sense as a as a
Halloween candy
uh I'm giving it an e
uh air heads not a fan of AirHeads
that's down here
Jolly Ranchers Jolly Ranchers is a good
hard candy I'd give it a s I'd give it a
c
jaw Busters or put them in the toilet
and flush them that's an F
it cat isn't bad I'd give KitKat like uh
if kick had a b
ffy Taffy is like a d
lemon heads
toilet absolutely not Baby Ruth isn't
bad I give a baby ruth like a b
Twizzlers I'm a fan of I'd give that
like a b Mike and Ike is a d Milk Duds
oh put them in the toilet Milky Way now
is Milky Way dark I'm a fan of Milky Way
is a good candy bar I'm gonna put it at
a on the understanding that I'm talking
here about the
um Milky Way dark
and then if it turns out that dark is
separate we'll we'll then figure that
out M Ms are good M M's are in a
um let's see what else we have here
Sweet Tarts are like a d Skittles I'm a
fan of I would give it a b Werther's
original horrible
uh Mr Goodbar
no no
popcorn I mean I like popcorn but
kind of a weird SD
Red Hots absolutely not Sour Patch Kids
are good I would I give Sour Patch Kids
like a give it a b
Reese's Pieces
the cups are okay Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups I consider to be an a now I'm gonna
be totally honest with you I would never
actually get the Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups I would get like the Trader Joe's
or Whole Foods dark chocolate peanut
butter cups I'm considering Reese's
Peanut Butter Cups as a placeholder for
a peanut butter cup
but I would never actually buy Reese's
it's filled with adulterations of all
kinds that I just don't want okay now
the Reese's Pieces
I would give like a b
Snickers is solid I would give it like
an a
peanut M M's I think peanut m m is is
absolute top tier I think that's a great
great candy bar Tootsie Rolls
it's like a like a it's like an e
Twix
I I think Twix is fantastic
Twix is fantastic nerds are trash down
here
Swedish Fish they get all in your teeth
and it's like I don't know guys I guess
it's like a d
um there's all sorts of other Twizzlers
here various types of Twizzlers
um
I kind of would put them all
as B I guess
another kind of Sour Patch Kids I can't
tell the difference Whoppers are toilet
nope absolutely not Whoppers are done
Hershey's
almond bar
yeah that's pretty good
Hershey's oh God milk chocolate
absolutely not we'll give that an e most
of these other things I haven't really
heard of
payday I could have sworn we did payday
already
isn't Payday on here
heyday
I guess not I would put payday
is not bad I would give it like a c
uh
Ring Pops give me a break guys
crunch is pretty good
I would give crunch like a b
all of this stuff is just terrible
terrible terrible terrible
double bubble come on guys
is this Hershey's white chocolate nah
I'm not being on white chocolate
I'll give it like a d
this other stuff I don't even know that
I'm gonna bother with oh wait is this
Starburst
assuming that's Starburst I'm a fan of
Starburst
I wish Mambo was on here mamba's a good
candy
all right I'm not gonna bother listen
the best things are an apple peanut M Ms
and Twix I I'm sorry guys it's what it
is oh rollos hold on where's yeah Rolo I
don't like it's like a d
this is my tier list okay
this is my tier list what I would
genuinely put at the top honestly now
what I would love at the top is
chocolate babka if I had gone to a door
on Halloween
and someone handed me a loaf of
chocolate babka
it it would have been absolutely
fantastic absolutely fantastic all right
thanks to agnostic sister for the twitch
Prime subscription thanks also to Buffy
bego Buffy but go for their YouTube uh
for the website membership thank you for
joining me subscribe like comment follow
all of it I will be back so soon with
many many more things
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
lathe
um
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm sorry
about getting rid of the machine just
pillows who did this attack who did the
Cyber attack so you have you know the
good Geeks and they patch it up and they
fix it and they put up better protection
virus protection but here's what my
attorney said he said
um
pillow they took the pillow phone do you
frequently go to Hardee's is that a
common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the lid to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that it should know if you're not giving
my phone I said arrest me I've done
nothing mommy said no we're not gonna
arrest you I swear you can do
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you some pillows I'm worried about
my legs
okay melting down and turn them into
prison bars
pillow all right